this is the time of year when many
Americans need to think about their
health insurance options for 2023. the
annual enrollment period is open for
individuals who have employer-sponsored
plans and those opting for government
plans through the Affordable Care Act
and Medicare CBS News business analyst
Jill Schlesinger is here with what you
need to know before this window closes
Good morning Joe how you doing I'm doing
well all right so what should people
consider when figuring out the best plan
for themselves you know these plans they
change every year and so our natural
human inclination is to say let me just
do what I did last year oh that is me
look over here hello my name is I get
overwhelmed by this every single year
and I just check exactly what I did so
here's the issue that's bad you're
saying it's bad because first of all if
your family circumstances changes maybe
you have to have different plan options
but the plans themselves change every
year so you may find that this year your
prescription drugs are covered under a
different plan but not under your
current plan so it's weird because it
requires you to do two levels of
research one is your family what do I
have what prescriptions do I have are my
doctors in the plan then you have to go
back to the plan itself and say are
there other plans and other Alternatives
that match up better for me it is time
consuming but it is worth it we are
talking about thousands and thousands of
dollars everywhere so you're saying
don't be lazy just do a little research
am I giving you a stink eye a little bit
okay
people that feel like this
vast majority and it is worth your time
because these things do change so I
encourage you to set so do you have a
cheat sheet on what's the main thing we
should be looking for and what should
factor into our decision-making
absolutely so the cheat sheet is this
first of all you say who are my doctors
that I see on a regular basis make a
list of them what are the drugs that I
take on a regular basis are you on high
are you on high blood pressure drugs is
your kid on asthma medication and then
you go to the plants and you say what is
covered now there are kind of three
variables when you look at your
insurance one is the actual premium what
it costs you each year but there's two
other aspects of this one is the
deductible what you have to pay out of
your pocket before your insurance kicks
in the other is co-pays so it's the
drugs the doctors the three variables
and now I've already lost Gail she's
checking no but aren't a lot of
companies already adding higher
deductibles too yes and so here's the
thing that's interesting the newest
iteration of health insurance is
something called a high deductible
Health Plan and this gains a lot of
currency especially with younger people
they're like I'm healthy I'll just pay a
higher deductible and then my because
I'm not gonna have to use it exactly my
premium will go down but it's also
really cool because a high deductible
plan is paired with something called a
health savings account so in order to
pay your high deductible you can put
money away pre-tax into an account it
grows without any taxation when you need
to take the money out to pay whatever
Bill whatever's out of pocket there's no
tax due it is called triple tax
advantage and so if you are not just
young and healthy but if you are older
and approaching retirement it's a great
way to save money because these are not
plans that you have to use or lose you
can carry them throughout your lives and
so I think the eight the high deductible
Health Plan paired with the health
savings account can be enormously
helpful for families and you can invest
the HSA money into in a stock market
account you can although listen if you
know you need this money in the next
year to pay that deductible it can't be
risky so you can do it as a safe stuff
or you can do some risky stuff if you're
over 65 you're eligible to be on
Medicare you recommend reviewing that
plan every year even if you're already
signed up why would that be because the
same thing happens with Medicare
suppliers and is it happens with our
employer suppliers because they change
plans and some doctors fall out of the
network some people flow in the drug
that was covered last year may not be
covered this year so the exact same
analysis where we look at the premium
the out-of-pocket the co-pays plus your
doctors and your drugs and the drugs
become so much more important because we
know people over 65 are more likely to
be on those medications same process
pain in the neck my mother calls me
every year she's like just do it and I
go through it and you know what it 85
percent of the time it is the same as
last year but a couple years I was like
wow this will cost mom three thousand
dollars out of pocket because one
medication has changed you have plans
this weekend I'm just going to come over
with my paperwork oh you're invited sit
with you and say okay Joe what what no
problem absolutely so you're making
plans for Jill yes I'll do your homework
and this is on her phone on the couch
yeah and I should just say one other
thing that the Affordable Care Act open
enrollment is occurring right now as
well and this is really important we
know a lot of people leaving employers
they're leaving the uh the Work World of
an employment-based plan and they're
going to be self-employment or gig check
out these plans four different levels
and by the way it is different in every
state so compare that you might get
subsidies so you might not have to
shoulder the burden on your own all
right the doctors the drugs deductibles
and co-pays
thank you so much thank you